monetary policy is a mixture of action
and communication you look at the market
reaction to what the ECB did today and
you have to ask where did the ECB fail
now I wouldn't say that what counts are
the decisions it is action that counts
of course and the markets might have
short-term reaction but they take the
action seriously and there has been
serious action today with five decisions
that are all important in my opinion and
I expect the market to recognize that
these were really really decisions that
count and again i really trust that the
short-term should not be considered any
i would say in any way an important
reaction well the market seem to think
there's a need for more stimulus the ECB
doesn't who's right no the market was
you know more or less creating more
expectations than was obviously in the
cart and what is being done by the ECB
and what works the most important
sentence in my opinion by Mario Draghi
today was if you do more it is not
because it failed but because it worked
and i really trust that it is true when
you look at the real economy where the
PMI for instance is good obviously when
you look at the diminishing of an
employment which over one year has been
quite substantial coming from 11.5 to
10.7 so something which is quite
significant when you look when you
compare with the other advanced economy
the PMI for instance you see that Europe
is going in the right direction it's a
long story of course it needs time and
it needs efforts a lot of efforts not
only of the central bank a lot of
efforts by governments Parliament's
social partners all those who have a
stake because the central bank cannot be
the only game in town well does that
bother you to the market reaction bother
you have central banks created and
healthy dependency in the markets on
central banks for intervention as my
friend Mohamed el-erian would say well
again what is very important but it was
a clear message of Mario today also as
was the case for all successive
president of the of the ECB we are not
the only game in town you have to do a
lot of structural reforms to elevate the
growth potential and the i would say
important decisions taken in particular
today but also before by the central
bank is giving time to other partners to
do their job to put their house in order
to clean the house are they going to do
that well this is absolutely necessary
the message of the central bank's is
very clear the message of the ECB is
very very clear some of them are doing
and I going in the right direction there
has been improvement in Europe of the
governance of the fiscal governance of
the of banking Union which is an
extraordinary important structural
reform a number of governments have to
also to proceed and do the job but that
is true for Europe it is true for all
advanced economy take us inside a
governing council meeting the story we
got today is that five members of the
governing council refused to go along
with additional stimulus how much
dissent is there within the meeting and
how much influence does dissenters have
on the policy ultimately adapted first
of all I will not comment on leaks
second when you decrease rates by 10
basis point negative 4 minus point 2 2
minus point 3 when you extend it quite
considerably the QE the present QE when
you decide to reinvest the retainment on
the previous investment these are
decisions that are very important so I
understand there has been a great
majority it was the world of my
successor for adopting these measures a
great majority for adopting these
measures so again major decisions in the
ECB as you know in my time also of
course we are taken on a simple majority
basis
most of the time it was a very great
majority in my time I had to resignation
of colleagues so decisions from time to
time are not easy to take obviously but
I toast really that the ECB took
decisions that are very important today
and the market will recognize that they
were indeed important